[Music]
ten days ago the world was watching
Windsor the home and final resting place
of the queen
and now the crowds are back inside the
castle and the chapel where the queen
Lies We watched the whole of the events
over the 10 days or so on television and
we were unable to get up and queue
personally because we're elderly and
having come we wanted to come here to
see what it was like it was it was
really amazing I didn't know what to say
was I started to cry I had to leave the
room so you started to cry when you saw
her gray yeah it was pretty sad
it's three weeks since the queen died
and now her death certificate published
an ordinary document for an
extraordinary life watermarked with the
Scottish Crown which sat on her coffin
as she lay in Edinburgh it states the
Queen's time of death as ten past three
in the afternoon the family announced
she died at half past six so we now know
many of them didn't make it in time and
her cause of death old age the same as
Prince Philip's last year
as for occupation those 70 years of rain
Simply Her Majesty the queen
and signed by her daughter Anne the
Princess Royal
but her home was Windsor Castle her
funeral procession ended here with the
committal service before a private
family burial
the queen is now at rest in the small
King George VI Memorial Chapel alongside
her husband her parents and her sister
there is a long line outside St George's
Chapel as people wait for their chance
to walk past the Queen's grave it is
quiet it is calm and inside one woman
turned to me and said I didn't expect to
feel this moved it all looks and feels
so final now
Grace and Anne camped outside overnight
for the lying in state queue and we're
back at the front in Windsor you were
the first to see her in the um lying
State and then we were the first to see
her here Windsor is the place the queen
came home to and now the place her
people come to to say their final
goodbyes Laura bundock Sky News Windsor